and
that sort of leads me to my to my next
thing about the
the superhero character you do have in
the dude which is drax
and i know from what i've heard you
really like worked your ass off
to get this throw it was it was not just
you know it wasn't just offered to you
you were you're in contention with other
actors you were yeah
and i'm wondering you know at this point
it's your three movies in
but to look back on that audition
process how much did it mean to you to
get that validation they're like you
have the role and you earn and you earn
the role
um you know what's weird man is um
it uh that that role changed the
trajectory of my life man
it's always going to be special to me
now
i'm um four films in which i can
confirm more on the way
um i really wish that they would have
i really wish that they would have
invested more in drax you know
personally
because i think drax has more of a story
to tell and i think draxler's got a
really
interesting backstory which they dropped
the ball on
and that's you know dick no dick on
marvel you know they had their slate and
i know what they're focused on and they
just that's what they had slated out
but man i think they really missed the
ball on drax i mean he's got such a
great backstory
and that would you know as selfishly as
a performer that would have given me the
opportunity to show like different sides
of traction emotionally
and physically as well because if you
notice like drax
you know although he looks like a badass
you look at him drax looks terrifying
drax gets his ass kicked more than any
other marvel character
for someone nicknamed the destroyer he
was very often getting exactly
and that's you know the whole destroyer
thing they just threw that out the
window but you know there was
you know shades of that you know that
they mentioned in the first film
but it's just i guess they you know
people fell so in love with the comedic
side of
if draxley just tapped into that and
then they tapped into it more and then
they just really dug a hole on it
but i think i think you know
you know we missed a huge boat on that
character and i don't think it'll ever
come back around but
i'm really just looking forward to kind
of finishing out this uh this whole
journey with the
the cash and everything now that's like
that's a full that's a full journey like
we started together and
not a lot of people unless you were
seriously in the comics really even knew
who the guardians were
and everybody was you know speculating
you know professional wrestlers playing
drags and you know is this going to be
the first
you know marvel film to flop and it was
a lot of that until it came out
people just fell in love with it and it
was almost like uh
um and this is not my word so i don't
want to get
beaten up by this but someone i i've
heard a lot of people say this is like
the new star wars and people
are going to look back on guardians the
way we look back our generation looks
back on star wars
and that like saying something like that
like that's a bold statement
and that like hits me and i you know
it's yet to be seen but if
if we could even if i you know could
have somebody
feeling that way about guardians the way
i feel and look back on star wars
i mean that's man that's a life worth
live man that's something
special i mean that's leaving uh that's
a legacy man so anyway
i'm really excited to wrap up this whole
journey with these guys i love them i
love the guardians cast like family
they know it i think i think everybody
knows it i'm pretty pretty vocal about
it
well i was i was going to ask i mean not
not to delve too much into the more
negative side of it but there was a bit
there where
we didn't know what was going on with
guardians 3. with the whole
the whole thing with with james and you
know at collider we were very
very vocally not not okay with it but
i'm wondering
sort of what it was like behind the
scenes at that moment and
what it's like to have that you know in
the past now
it was at the time it was awful and
thank you for being vocal and that was
that was the one thing that
you know really made it it just made it
okay and it just helped me a lot because
i got
man i got beat up and i got bashed and i
got threatened
and i got you know i was in a bad spot
with disney as well but i just you know
i just felt like i was
doing the right thing and i felt like
you know a friend a guy who really
went out on a limb for me and kind of
changed my life was
being unfairly attacked and he was
unfairly attacked
and then he was unfairly punished and so
i i just couldn't live with myself if i
didn't say anything but it was
at the time it was awful like it was
awful and i literally stayed
like on social media at that time even
though i was just getting bashed and
beaten up i stayed on it
because i knew if you know nobody was
speaking up for him then he was just
there was just no chance
and this was like a wrong this was like
a part of you know the climate the
political climate the
you know things that were going on this
was like even much bigger than james
this was like
this was like a big message that they
were sending uh this was a personal
political attack on james gunn and you
know i
you know disney i just don't i think
they they jumped the gun
they made a rash decision uh they made a
mistake
and i think you know eventually they
they really did the right thing and
which was another huge statement
for disney to go back and say hey guys
we made a mistake we're going to hire
we're hiring james back i mean that in
itself is a huge statement
and so yeah i don't want to overlook
that at all that was something that like
they really
even put themselves out on a limb which
they didn't need to do because they
could have moved on
and just gone on without and they still
in the next guardians would made a load
of money and people would come out to
see it because they're so invested in it
but they didn't they did they did the
right thing they said hey guys we made a
mistake
and that in itself is a message but
there was no there was no way in hell
that i was just gonna leave james
hanging out there to fight for himself
and defend himself
for something that he wasn't guilty of
it was just a designed attack by
horrible people you know horrible people
and there's just no way i was just gonna
you know sit there and do nothing about
it saying nothing about it and you guys
too
like it it really helped a lot and it
made me feel good to see that so many
like big outlets were coming
out and saying this isn't this not right
this is not okay
and we can't let these guys get away
with it because if this if they get away
with this
this is going to continue to happen and
it's going to get it worse and this you
know it's
going to be a snowball going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger uh so a lot
of people
you know they really stepped up up to
the plate and stood up for james which
needed to happen because he needed help
and uh so yeah thankfully they they
hired him back and because he was
already on suicide squad
things got really arranged guardians got
pushed but it's done deal man we're
making we're making that film man we're
going into it um later this year and
it's signed shield and delivered to do
it i'm excited about it and uh
and yeah that's it man we'll wrap up
this story
and i asked about the dune script but
what's your sort of first reaction to to
james's guardians 3 script
i haven't read it i haven't read it
already
yeah i haven't read it and and i will
and we'll sit down eventually we'll go
james is big on rehearsals
big on table reads so that'll probably
be the first time that i'll actually
read it as we go and sit down and do the
table read
yeah which will be in november of this
year